well every three years the council has
to produce a long-term plan so for the
2015
2025 year the council has to spell out
its program of works and its levels of
service and how it's going to fund those
so we've got some major issues in the
next 10 years that we have to to get to
grips with and we're asking the
ratepayers and the residents to give us
some feedback on those
key issues now some of those key issues
include reducing the levels of service
for example the
government or the nzta are reducing its
funding for roads uh by one percent a
year so they're roughly giving us sixty
percent at the moment that's going to
reduce by one percent so we we are
suggesting that the level of of service
for roads will will be less smooth and
they'll reduce over that 10-year period
and our footpath program is going to
reduce as well so we need some feedback
on that there are some works that we
have to do and we've got a problem with
sewage treatment for kennington
residents so they're going to connect on
to the pipeline and that's going to come
into the the city
surge treatment plant the wastewater
treatment plant at clifton needs to have
some money spent about a million dollars
to upgrade it so that the consents can
still be
used going forward in the future but the
major issue that's facing us
infrastructure wise is our water pipes
we've got asbestos pipes about 40
percent
of our network is water pipes and some
testing has shown that those pipes may
not last the 100 years or the 65 years
that they were expected to do
and so therefore we're going to have to
progressively increase our program of
water improvement and replacing those
pipes so that's going to cost over 20
million in the next 10 year
plan so we need some feedback we've also
looking at the levels of service for
parks and reserves and that's you know
we're looking at we've got a very high
level of parks compared to the national
average and some of those parks aren't
getting utilized so what we've decided
to do is maybe sell some of those off
and reduce those those number of parks
and transfer the money into the existing
parks that are getting well used that
need new new equipment we're also
looking at the splash palace which is
really a success story and it's getting
a lot of use at the moment at splash
palace
but the changing facilities there are
inadequate and we're also looking at a
fitness centre there as well to help
cope with help pay for that
we need to extend splash palace really
for two main reasons there are two key
components i think to this first of all
we're exceeding by a long way the the
design limitations on the building and
and i mean that in terms of the number
of people that we have entering the
facility so last year for example we had
over 370 000 people come through and and
the numbers were just never estimated to
be that high and as a result of that
we're running out of things like
changing room space
car parking is an issue
we see problems in our cafe and foyer
area um
getting comprised because of the number
of people in there so these plans really
address that issue the second thing of
course is that we've had feedback over
the years that suggest people would like
to see a gymnasium at splash palace
and and what we believe we can do
through the addition of a gym is that we
can fund both the gymnasium and the
additional change room space and
four-year space
and achieve kill two birds with one
stone if you like it's funded through
loan funding so we would take a loan for
the entire works and that loan would be
repaid through user charges over over 20
years so there's no rate funding that
goes into this project
councils produced a park strategy which
looked at the appropriateness of ground
and reserve areas in the empirical
district and each of those areas have a
different category whether it's a
playground or a sports field or whatever
and that has revealed some surpluses in
some areas and also then they've
produced a play strategy which indicated
where the play equipment should be
relating to where the children are in
their makoko district currently we have
80 neighborhood
parks
and each of those have got one or two
pieces of equipment on this will be
reduced down to 52 which will have a
better range of equipment on
for children to play give them greater
play experience
at this stage they're considering
disposal of approximately 10 areas
and a lot of these undeveloped areas
areas that have been obtained in the
past where the city hasn't grown
and
so the idea is to rationalize those and
end up with
reserve areas um they'll go through this
process people can consult through the
long-term plan on whether they want to
see the reserve disappear from the area
and if council decides to go ahead with
it we'll then advertise again via the
reserves act and give people a second
chance at putting submissions in on it
at the moment in the consultation
document there's three prime areas this
firstly there's the water supply issue
where we're looking to renew renew the
ic mains earlier than we had expected
and within the stormwater and surge
areas there's our pipes that are coming
to the end of their lives as well and
they need to be they need to be replaced
and in the roading area there are some
changes to the way it's funded and the
level of service that we're looking to
provide going forward within the water
pipes the the ac pipes were laid
asbestos cement pipes were laid in the
1950s through the 1980s and they had an
original life of about 65 years but what
we've found through some recent bursts
and some sampling is that those pipes
are starting to fail earlier than we had
expected so within the consultation
document there is a proposal to actually
bring those planned renewals
forward from where they previously were
so that's about 55 million over the next
10 years as planned to upgrade those
pipes
so what that will mean is that there is
a rate there is a rise in the amount
that ratepayers are asked to contribute
for the water for the water section and
within the consultation document it
gives some options that they can select
and give some feedback on
within roading there's there's two
things that are happening one is the new
zealand transport agency provide council
and other councils throughout the
country with
funding and what's been indicated over
the next nine years that's going to
reduce by one percent so what we're
finding what we will find is that
ratepayers will have to contribute more
but at the same time they've also
indicated that our roads are actually
smoother than the national average of
roads so what they're also asking us is
for us to do less less work on them and
then they reduce to their towards that
average and that's over the next nine
years that will be occurring
on an individual carriageway section by
section people won't see much but what
it does mean is that they will get
slightly rougher and we'll have to focus
and prioritise where we actually
undertake works
the real problem that we're looking at
and asking for feedback on is that the
rate increase for next year is proposed
to be 3.71 and an average of about 3.8
over the next 10 years we've got a lot
of people on fixed incomes and
affordability issues are a concern
so we want to get get some feedback from
the ratepayers and residents how they
feel about it are we spending too much
are we not spending enough on the right
areas are the levels of service that
we're proposing to provide the next 10
years are they adequate or not adequate
so submissions starting on the 25th
of april and go through to the 25th of
may you can get a copy of our website or
from the service center in bluff the
library or at the civic administration
building
and
submissions are open and we'd like to
get your feedback and
input into those
you